there are two blessings that people
greatly take for granted it's free time
and health the other one but you guys
have heard it's an authentic hadith
talking about taking advantage of five
before five and one of those things is
health even I'll claim a great physician
is scholar he emphasizes this point he
talks about health is one of the most
precious favors from the Almighty from
the crater one of the most precious
favors that the Creator has bestowed
upon his servants the most generous of
gifts the most plentiful of his bounties
rather than even more health is the most
precious of favors without exception so
it's fitting that whoever is granted a
portion of it of this fortune that he
cherishes it he cherishes at health that
blessing he preserves it health and he
guards it against harm and chronic
disease brothers and sisters this is one
of the greatest issues affecting our
health let me share with you some
staggering statistics that really pushed
this point home do you know that we are
the first generation kids in this
generation are the first of its kind not
expected to outlive their parents did
you understand that let that sink in did
you know that the government is
expecting by 2040 that it's federal
budget 100 percent of it will be going
towards Medicare and Medicaid 100
percent by 24 that's how rapidly chronic
disease is spreading it's a health
crisis an epidemic the department can
does the Department of Defense has named
chronic disease as an existential threat
to this country let that sink in did you
know that over a hundred million not a
hundred thousand you know your zeros
hundred million people living in America
us Americans here I'm born here most of
you born here Americans we love our
country right of course people have
diabetes or pre-diabetic but death sink
in and most people they don't know that
they have or that they're expected to
have full-blown diabetes too and it
usually takes to progress about five
years am i correct we got two doctors in
the houses right yeah 30% of kids have
chronic diseases 30% one in two
Americans has a chronic disease that's
50% of America
one in two let's see the me or you let
it not be either of us or any of us God
willing one in three have multiple
chronic diseases you guys understand my
english hablas espanol 40% 40% of
Americans are obese add that with the
30% that are overweight that's 70% obese
or overweight I'm almost done and then
we'll bring on our special guests one in
two of Americans are expected to have
cancer one and two very scary very sad
and this all comes from chronic diseases
that are reversible that by lifestyle
choices by food choices as our guests
now are going to come on and talk about
we can go ahead
and be God willing not included in this
statistic and we can start to help honor
this vehicle that the Creator has given
us to get us through life by cherishing
it by preserving it and guarding it
against many of these chronic diseases
that are affecting the majority of us
living today so let me bring on our next
speaker Jim Marlow
you